it sounds very very sexual you're doing
it wrong do this new character model is
like firm who's very serious then it's
like uh uh locked on target
[Applause]
you should have read the cautions I'm
old I do they van gogh's out there do
you love me or yamimash well of course
they're gonna say they love you you see
me no I saw something there was a thing
standing in the way there was something
I didn't believe you I just okay what's
in there ah infant hallo
you shut up don't make fun of the way I
run what would your crew buy wins this
is the America how about you jump up do
not touch a thing
there is a button up on the I don't
trust this door it doesn't seem right oh
wow I'm gonna name him yummy baby
I'm gonna feed him bear its arm yes
please freedom beer as is the British
tradition you cut off by a door that
just appeared oh my god
no try that one I bet that one's the one
do not bother him
[Music]
oh no sign that chair for you okay ah
[Laughter]
you got me
I know we will see you what are you
doing with that oh wait sorry watch this
you ruined it for me I'll just stand
right behind you and I won't do anything
now it's time for the real nightmare to
begin
[Music]
are you done yamimash love hide and seek
you got so five-o what does it even mean
to be human do any of us even really
know can any of us we even really say I
don't know anymore
[Laughter]
ya know did we do it hi yeah okay I
think we did it this has been a special
markiplier highlights in dedication to
my good friend yamimash thank you so
much for all the amazing collabs I
wouldn't be here without you so check
out his channel for even more great
videos and some videos that we've done
together that you may not have seen
thanks again everybody for watching and
as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye